when we did an analysis for one
president of how they used their time we
found that less than five percent of
their times was on their priorities so
you had these priorities but actually
they weren't spending any time on it
one great advice piece of advice that
was given to me by a former president of
yours President Clinton actually was was
this this is I went to see him in in
1996 in the in the White House when I
was leader of the Opposition and you
know we had a good meeting every leading
leaving he said to me I want to talk to
you about something really important and
I thought you know I was quite taken
with this I thought I was gonna get some
in straw Denari piece of geopolitical
insight there was about a bee
he's even president then for a count I
six years in his second term I thought
he's gonna tell me there's a secret code
you know and he said I said so I was
very excited by so I said what is it and
he said I'm gonna talk to you about
scheduling and he he explained to me
which is absolutely right not that he
always does that or I was do it in the
way we think it should be done by the
way but he said to me you will find that
one of the hardest things when you get
in the government is finding the time to
think strategically is being able to
create the space so that you are focused
on what you really know counts because
otherwise he said the system will take
you over and you'll be a meetings from
8:00 in the morning till 10:00 at night
and you know you'll think you're
immensely busy but actually the tactics
and the strategy have all got mixed
together it was great advice which I
actually took and I found that
invaluable and one of the first things I
say to any prisoners where's your
thinking time where's your consideration
of where am I going what am I trying to
do have I got this thing really because
what happens in politics as well is that
things come at you the whole time so you
know there's a British prime minister
wasn't
one Sassin he said what's the most
difficult thing about government and he
said events did boy events you know
that's what so things happen right and
if you're not careful something happens
is a some crisis and you spend your time
dealing with you lose your strategic
grip on on what's gonna determine
whether you're a successful government
or not
now these crises are real you got to
deal with them but actually when you
then judge your government in history
you know I think of the things that I
lost sleep on some of the you know
crises that suddenly came like so
foot-and-mouth disease or in a fuel
strike or so nowadays no one even
remembers any of those things but you've
got to create the space to be thinking
strategically all the time change the
world